this is sort of a standard question but
it always gets great answers best piece
of advice and what was it and worst
pieces of advice and what was it oh no
one named names the best piece of advice
I got was from a professor in film
school and he said do what you love and
the money will come and I know that I
mean he that's not his quote but it was
the first time I had heard it and I
think it's very important to remember to
keep doing what you love and the money
will come don't focus on the money
because when you start focusing on the
money
you make decisions that aren't
necessarily the ones you'd make based on
love so that to me was the best piece of
advice the worst piece of advice was
probably you don't have to change
anything it's your script and you know
there is always this thing about how
much should you change you know before
you're selling out how much should you
change that a producer wants you to
change it how much did you fight for
your own vision my feeling on that is
you can fight on the next one sell the
script right and get the credit and get
the money and at some point as you kind
of progress through your career you get
more and more power and then you have to
change less and less so but you got to
get there first so early in your career
do what they need you to do make them
happy you're the client
they're the client I mean you know do
what they want and and make the changes
you know you can stick to - you're your
own creative vision on the next one so
with both pieces of advice did you agree
or disagree with them right away or did
it take some time it took time and you
know very early in my career I did that
I pulled the script away it was actually
my thesis script that I wrote in film
school I had a producer interested in
buying it and after he gave me the notes
I was convinced he didn't get the
project he just doesn't understand it
and pulled the script away and I ended
up never selling that script and I don't
know if it would have made any
difference in how my career went or not
you just you don't know but in
retrospect that was me being a prima
donna and thinking that I knew more and
once that happened that experience
happened I lost that attitude which
probably served me very well for the
rest of my career so I kind of hope that
most writers have that experience early
on because that will help them and then
with the best piece oh do what you love
the money well I mean I'm thinking of
the book is a Virginia Virginia signed
tour or something I think I have that
book actually at home and I read it too
because I was in a place where I didn't
know but but did you because I had
trouble believing that concept it's it's
hard to believe that concept right well
I heard it so young that I actually did
believe it initially because when you're
in college you're not jaded yet you
haven't actually been in the real world
but but you do lose it you absolutely
lose it because you know when the money
starts to not come you the first thing
you do is question that right and you
start to compromise and but the reality
is even through all those difficult
periods and and they will happen
especially if you're a writer especially
if you're freelance than anything stick
to what you love because it will it will
happen it will happen and you just have
to to keep the faith
I know it's hard it really is but my
life is proving it I feel like and I
think if you stick with it long enough
almost everybody's life will prove that
you